en 1990 le 4 juillet au matin nous
traversez Neuilly pour vous rendre à
votre bureau quand vous entendez une
gigantesque explosion le problème c'est
que vous êtes le seul à l'avoir entendu
[Musique]
Philippe Vigan bonsoir accompagné de son
épouse Stéphane Vigan bonsoir voilà
alors Philippe Vigan vous êtes atteint
du
loct-indrome où le syndrome
d'enfermement une affection neurologique
rare qui se manifeste par une paralysie
de tous les muscles du corps sauf les
paupières vous êtes conscient vos
capacités intellectuelles sont intactes
et vous êtes incapable de bouger ou de
vous exprimer vous êtes en muré vivant
Philippe cette histoire vous la racontez
dans un livre témoignage intitulé
légumes verts publié chez Anne Carrière
on en reparle à 20h
[Musique]
Stéphane et Philippe Vigan rebondsoir
Philippe vous êtes né le 6 mai 1957 à
Boulogne vous êtes ce qu'il convient
d'appeler un fils de bonne famille père
marchand de bien passionné par la chasse
à courre et la Sylvie culture en seconde
vos parents vous envoient en pension
dans la fameuse école des roches dans
l'Eure c'est là que vous passez un bac
scientifique que vous repasserez pour
obtenir une mention bien vous intégrez
l'ISG l'Institut Supérieur de Gestion et
en 1981 le soir de Noël vous rencontrez
Stéphane vous avez 25 ans elle a 20 ans
c'est le coup de foudre 9 mois plus tard
vous vous mariez voilà alors Philippe
vous êtes d'abord embauché par Matra
avant de devenir contrôleur de gestion
chez Hachette Philippe à qui
mais le week-end c'est toujours chasse à
courre et golf vous êtes parmi les 100
meilleurs joueurs de golf français
Stéphane chef de pub dans une agence de
communication vous avez deux filles tout
va bien et là en 1990 le 4 juillet au
matin nous traversez Neuilly pour vous
rendre à votre bureau quand vous
entendez une gigantesque explosion le
problème c'est que vous êtes le seul à
l'avoir entendu
à ce moment là vous pensez à quoi
tout de suite
su que c'était grave
il a tout de suite c'était grave ensuite
vous vous traînez jusqu'à un café où on
appelle le SAMU et vous Stéphane donc
vous retrouvez Philippe aux urgences à
ce moment-là il peut encore parler oui
il parlait très très mal mais il m'a
tout de suite dit effectivement c'est
très grave et fais quelque chose sauf
que il y avait pas grand chose à faire
il était entre les mains de spécialistes
et puis voilà quoi le scanner ne révèle
rien d'anormal
et puis pendant la nuit les choses se
compliquent vers 2h Philippe tente de se
lever mais là vous découvrez que vous ne
tenez pas sur vos jambes
oui
à 6h du matin vous ne répondez plus aux
questions et vous sombrez dans le coma
et là les médecins sont incapables de
dire ce qui s'est passé
ils vous disent c'est un accident
vasculaire mais c'est tout alors il faut
remettre les choses dans leur contexte
c'était il y a 20 ans les choses ont
vraiment évolué depuis je pense que la
prise en charge aurait pu être
différente aujourd'hui précisément alors
après deux mois de coma vous renoncez et
là vous ne ressentez rien d'anormal
c'est absolument incroyable c'est-à-dire
que même vous vous flashez sur une belle
kiné
les yeux marchent bien le sourire là
aussi quand vous vous réveillez du coma
vous êtes dans un sentiment d'apesanteur
c'était le contraire il avait peur de
tomber du lit
sans arrêt
alors vu de l'extérieur c'est autre
chose parce que votre mari a le visage
amaigri
déformé asymétrique surtout immobilier
il y avait vraiment que les yeux qui
clignaient et tout le temps pour tout
et puis il a une trachéotomie en plus
oui donc de toute façon j'ai pas réalisé
tout de suite que le fait qu'il ne
reparlerait pas serait définitif
traquer on peut pas parler à ce
moment-là donc Philippe au moment où
vous réveillez de ce coma
vous réalisez que vous avez toute votre
tête vos sensations mais vous êtes en
muret vivant le loking drum
ouais
donc c'est là que vous mettez au point
un premier code oui c'est un clignement
de paupière non ces deux clignements de
paupières c'est un début comme ça c'est
comme si on rencontre des
extraterrestres quoi on met au point un
système extrêmement primitif de
communication un jour un médecin vous
pose une question et vous dit combien
font 2 et 2 vous répondez quoi
il fait des vannes
alors là effectivement vous dites
Philippe la prison semblait s'ouvrir un
peu voilà et finalement grâce à une amie
à vous vous allez pouvoir vous exprimer
presque librement disons l'idée c'est de
classer les lettres en deux tableaux un
tableau de consonnes un tableau de
voyelle et puis bah vous clignez des
yeux pour montrer la colonne et la ligne
voilà j'ai un gros progrès
c'est toujours celui qui l'utilise
aujourd'hui c'est comme un jeu de
toucher couler A2
l'indique d'abord la colonne puis la
ligne et donc on a on avance comme vous
venez de le voir l'aide par lettre et
donc votre première phrase après deux
mois de silence c'est c'est mal aux
pieds et vous en fait vous dites que il
a dit je t'aime c'est quoi la vraie
et là alors ce qui est extraordinaire
dans votre histoire à tous les deux
c'est que là vous faites un enfant quand
on vous demande comment on fait un
enfant avec le looking syndrome vous
répondez n'en déplaise aux mauvaises
langues on fait comme tout le monde un
soir d'amour
ce qu'il faut dire en fait c'est que les
sensations de Philippe sont intactes en
fait et même les zones érogènes
évidemment par le même occasion mais
vous avez ressenti de la suspicion et de
la réprobation autour de vous à ce
moment-là c'est impensable pour les gens
Philippe ne bouge pas donc il ne sent
pas donc il n'entend pas donc il ne
enfin c'est comme si c'était un légume
voilà alors ensuite ma trame est au
point un ordinateur sur lequel il suffit
de fixer une lettre pendant une
demi-seconde pour la taper et là
effectivement ça devient magique quoi
parce que Philippe peut écrire voilà
c'est un ordinateur qui fonctionne il y
a une petite caméra qui filme son oeil
et il baladent l'un de ses yeux sur
l'écran sur lequel il y a un éclan un
écran virtuel et les lettres s'écrivent
c'est comme un doigt c'est l'oeil qui
fait doigt alors après un séjour à
Garches en rééducation un autre séjour à
Kerpape en Bretagne Philippe vous
revenez chez vous et là vous réalisez en
fait que vous gênez un peu c'est à dire
que vous êtes extrêmement exigeant parce
que vous venez de l'hôpital où tout le
monde était à votre service toute la
journée et vous vous rendez compte qu'il
faut vous faire un peu oublier c'est
quand même énorme dans votre cas dans un
comble
vous avez souffert de ça
c'est bien
à
faire oublier ça pas toujours été le cas
c'est sûr
on est normaux il y a pas de problème
ça prend du temps
le problème de l'engueulade c'est qu'il
faut que je traduise
un petit peu oublié quand vous rentrez
chez vous là le problème c'est de
redevenir un père de famille alors
l'avantage c'est que quand les enfants
vous disent qu'est-ce que je fais vous
demande une permission vous dites
demande à papa parce que lui c'est écrit
donc une fois que c'est écrit c'est
incontournable et puis comme ils veulent
pas le traduire parce que c'est
fatiguant c'est oui ou non ah oui donc
il y a pas de discussions
c'est que
c'est
c'est que c'est décalé oui le problème
c'est que le temps de réponse n'est pas
immédiat donc quelquefois ça tombe un
peu à plat
alors soit ça a plus de force soit ça en
perd un peu alors vos deux filles
agissent différemment capucine dit je
veux changer de famille elle s'en va
enfin après elle revient mais dans un
premier temps elle est partie et quand
elle est revenue derrière c'était bien
l'autre Juliette n'est pas perturbé elle
dit je préfère avoir un papa handicapé
comme un papa mort
après être devenu un bon papa il faudra
redevenir un bon mari alors évidemment
on peut dire la vérité c'est que jouer
les infirmières ça booste pas
spécialement le désir quand on s'occupe
de quelqu'un comme ça toute la journée
mais Philippe compense par des par les
attentions c'est si vous vous engueulez
vous offre un bouquet de fleurs par
exemple
c'est bien là c'est mieux que les autres
il fait il fait beaucoup d'efforts pour
faire des surprises souvent
que les hommes font pas toujours je
remarque sur les autres bon alors je
pense qu'il t'apprends c'est ça a
développé sa créativité clairement pour
me garder
en tous les cas je trouve qu'il est très
malicieux
alors évidemment aujourd'hui Philippe
vous connaissez de bons moments lire
l'équipe évidemment grands moments
insister à un concert de la CDC le bain
chaud mais surtout l'orange pressé le
matin ça c'est le grand moment
c'est
je
fait
L
on a compris
grand moment c'est lorsqu'il fait
l'amour est-ce que la vie comme ça vaut
le coup d'être vécue
bien sûr
je
qui change tout c'est qui formidable
l'amour que vous avez pour lui c'est
extraordinaire
oui
vraiment de plaisir à voir vraiment et
pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
innarditude abonnez-vous et mettez un
pouce bleu